this is a production of Cornell
University hi everyone my name is keny
Rodriguez I am a PhD student at Corell
University and today I'm here with Steve
rers he's a Horticulture specialist and
today we're talking about we're going to
be talking about flowering on curbit so
Steve sometimes people wonder if there
are like females and male plants that we
need to plant in order to get
pollenization and to get fruit or
sometimes people don't get u fruit in
their plants so can you talk us a little
bit about that and how does the
flowering influence um the fruit
producing in the Cur beads sure and
curbit they're different than a lot of
other things for example tomatoes have
what we call perfect flowers flowers
have both male and female parts within
within a single flower in curbit and
we're talking squash and pumpkins and
cucumbers and melons um with those they
have male and female flowers and we have
a perfect example of it right here in
this plant right next to each other for
example so here this is going to be a
male flower easy to tell because if you
look at the base of the flower there's
no immature fruit on that as compared to
this right next to it you can see here's
a flower and then you can see this
immature fruit you can notice the
difference between these two so we've
got male flowers we got the female
flowers and here's another female flower
here that's even a little bit further
along and that flower is just opening up
now the male flowers typically there's
going to be maybe 10 or 12
um in a season for every one single
female flow that we're going to get and
the male flour and I'm going to just
pull this one off I'm going to open it
up because there could be a pollinator
in there sometimes there are but there's
not in here but again this is where the
pollen is and bees and other pollinators
will go into that flower they're going
to actually they're going for some
nectar that's at the bottom of that
flower but they're also getting some of
the pollen as well and as they're in
there they get that pollen all over
themselves and then they go to a female
flower like what we will have here and
you can see here and then they're
bringing that the pollen onto the sticky
part the stigma of the female flower
which is what what's right up there at
top and moving that pollen over that
gives us fruit set if for some reason we
don't have bees M now there could be
bees but maybe it's been a week of rainy
weather or it's been really hot if you
don't have the bees moving from the male
flowers to the female flowers what can
happen is eventually um this will start
to get a little B bigger but because you
didn't have any pollen move you didn't
have fruits it eventually this will
yellow and just fall right off so people
sometimes will panic when they see these
and they they see these open and then
they don't see any fruit and that's
normal it's a male flower if you're
seeing these opening up and these are
falling off and again you look for that
immature fruit um then you you could
potentially have a problem so do all
plants Dan have female male FL
flowers um all curbit yes all curbit for
the most part would be exceptions
because some are have only female
flowers and we have to put some other
plants out there pollinators is what we
call them because they'll have male
flowers um so if we just had a feel of
nothing but female flowers we wouldn't
really get anything this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell.edu